the war in ukraine has upended the lives
of millions of people including the
country's lgbtq community the country's
biggest pride event had to be moved to
poland last sunday and thousands of gays
and lesbians have joined the effort to
defend their country with many fighting
on the front lines raymond ascencio
shows us how the pride community is
doing as the war shows no signs of
ending
[Music]
cave pride was never supposed to be held
outside of ukraine's capital but among
the rainbow flags at warsaw pride in
neighboring poland ukraine's ubiquitous
blue and yellow i'm here because i can't
go to pride in ukraine because we're all
people irregardless of who we love
central europe's biggest pride march
keeping the world focused on ukraine's
fight against russia and its lgbt plus
communities fight for equal rights
these halls are from shrapnel
victor pilipenko is a gay medic on the
front line in donetsk and founder of
ukraine's union of the lgbt plus
military it counts thousands among its
members
do you as a gay soldier get different
treatment no actually no we are equal
here
as well as we are fighting for freedom
of our country
many of his colleagues here have died by
his side he says he's never felt
discrimination and says it's important
to be out because openness changes pains
changes attitudes
he's got far to go nearly one in two
ukrainians feel negatively of the gay
community but that's falling slowly with
the youth the more religious and more
pro-russian areas are the least tolerant
russians didn't have any option for us
like you can't protect human rights in
ukraine without gun now
in thieves bohemian gay-friendly padil
district we met boris milowski right
before he returned to the front lines
he's fought this war since the start not
for land or money or even gay rights
specifically it's
my personal freedom is
my needs to live in like freedom country
this democracy institution your
president vladimir zenski yeah you like
him yeah no i'm
i'm fond of congrats with him right now
that's because he's unified ukrainians
against russia's invasion and the hate
crimes bill and same-sex civil union
bill are now on the table
back on the front lines victor says
ukraine can't lose the war it will be a
complete disaster putin's ideology is a
homophobia
so
disrespect towards human rights
and a country walking back freedoms it's
only just begun to celebrate out of
russia's shadow a show of pride and
defiance hoping the world will see and
support even more for cbs morning's
raymie innocencio kiev
got to say i was it was in that part of
warsaw in march with the president that
city has embraced its neighbors from
ukraine like like in a really impressive
way so it's nice to see it continuing
love wins
that's the message love wins love wins